the one the only the hall of famer bill
walton here on the rich eisen show how
are you bill
yeah here we go
i'm alive i'm married to lori she's
still here
i haven't broken any tesla windshields
today i'm on the rich eisen show
so what could be better it's a beautiful
day in southern california
it's a wonderful opportunity to
celebrate the greatness
of all that we have and to lift the
spirits
of those in need to ease the pain and
the burden
and come together as a team as a
community and with the collective sense
of effort and purpose and let's get this
thing
going right now yes
tonight man incredible you got the early
game arizona and yukon
oh my gosh adia barnes she's from our
hometown san diego here
gino is just absolutely spectacular don
staley i've known her forever south
carolina
and then tara at stanford this is going
to be
incredible and then tomorrow you got the
men you got
the early game with uh houston i love
cougars and then the baylor bears are
growling and then gonzaga yeah ucla
let's play what do we have to wait for
my goodness gracious yes the moment of
truth that we're
all anticipating so much we wanted to be
there
but as the great champion has to be yes
you've got to be patient and you've got
to wait for the start before you come
out with a volcanic explosion
which is pretty much the way the gonzaga
bulldogs play
every time and ucla better be ready from
the first
cap because we saw what happened with
usc and usc
what a remarkable team and season they
had and all the players and the coach
and
the whole usc community i believe that's
where i broke
your windshield yes that was oh my god
on the campus at usc for the katy perry
video by the way
i don't know if you're aware bill can
you get the number of
people who have actually downloaded that
video on youtube who has actually seen
it
it's in nine figures bill it is easily
the most viewed thing i've ever done was
that video that you and i shot
at uh at usc for katy perry that was a
fantastic day
just a joy and a privilege thrill and an
honor i've done a lot of things in my
life
and but few things rank rate or compare
with that
i don't really try to get into that i
just try to enjoy every moment as i hope
these ball players do
both the men and the women's side yes
and and so
but when i got to be with you when i got
to sit there
and someone who i grew up watching
someone who i just grew up dreaming
that i could one day do something the
way with my life the way that rich eisen
has been able to do with his
because as a lifelong stutterer it is so
difficult speaking is my biggest
challenge athletics
basketball i was the easiest part of my
life and then academics that was next
straight a student but man
that's orthopedic health challenges 39
operations
all the replaced parts all the fusions
but even more so than that was the
speech impediment and
to have you in my life to have chick
hearn in my life to have bob costas and
all the guys that we've worked with
ralph lawler and chick hearn
and just the amazing number of people
i've come across when you and i got
together that day with katy perry at the
gala center
i had reached the top of the mountain it
was absolutely the pinnacle
and i've been trying to duplicate
replicate get back to that top i'm
struggling
i'm working my way back up i'm trying to
get there put me in coach i'm ready to
play today well it's funny you say
mountain because the mountain was also
there in the video too
i guess i've never been around somebody
almost as big as you
uh bill and that was in a 635
million people have seen that video that
we did that day
wait a second yes yes sir you're saying
that 635 million
yes saul have have on youtube alone
seen that video that's on its way to a
billion
yes it's correct that is correct
that is dealing with lots of billions
lately i've been i just finished last
night this incredible book
the wizard and the prophet by charles
mann please check it out it's this
remarkable story
of life and history and science and
technology and biology and genetics and
ecology it is
just fantastic story and incredible
research and depth
charles mann the wizard and the prophet
and you're kind of both you are the
wizarding
prophet because you deliver you deal and
i remember i think the last show we were
on we were doing something for the
pandemic to raise money for feeding
america
and here it was and you and i and snoop
dogg and uh
dion sanders and we had just an
incredible fundraiser there it was
fantastic what we did
uh just to be a part of something
special and i've learned so much from
all of you guys i'm truly the luckiest
guy in the world bill walton here on the
rich eisen show part of westwood one's
coverage of the final four
is it true you and kareem howard rob how
lucky are we
i mean this is like i got i got to marry
lori
i had the greatest parents in the world
every coach and teacher i had as a child
was a john wooden chick hearn disciple
i got to know chick hearn i got to play
for john wooden
i know rich eisen and now i work with
jim gray
and howard i mean i am the luckiest dude
on earth i'm thrilled and is it true you
and kareem are having a chit chat that's
going to air during the broadcast
we've got a lot of things going on now
last night so
make sure we get back to that shut uh
last night uh the
the ucla basketball alumni all got
together
on a big zoom conference call and it was
just a gigantic love fest and their
kareem led the way tyus edmu in the
athletic department now at ucla he
organized the thing mike warren lucius
allen jamal wilkes marcus johnson
greg lee andy hill it was just andre
mccarter
pete turkovich it was absolutely a
tremendous time and they
were just so we're so thrilled we're so
excited
inspired proud and happy for these guys
these new guys who
who are just playing so tough and so
wonderful
i was there in oakland in 2006 when
ucla was just hammered and pounded by
gonzaga
in the ncaa tournament and we were ready
to leave we were ready to get up and get
out of the building because it was
getting kind of embarrassing
and then i i leaned to lori and i said
you know what if we get up and leave
early here they're going to put us on tv
and that's going to just not
so let's stick it out and so in the
closing moments ucla scores the last 11
points of the game right and adam
morrison there's a great friend and a
wonderful player and college player of
the year
he's on the floor crying and sadness and
disbelief we're looking at each other
and we can't figure out
did the bruins really win this game what
happened what just happened
and then we it was late and it was in
oakland there was no place to go we were
starving so we ended up at a
mexican restaurant in the mission
district of san francisco
and we all night man everything was
flowing we closed the place down
we opened it up the next morning and we
taught the mariachi band the ucla fight
song
it was awesome i mean what uh
what what what what what talk about
kareem yeah so
so later later we're getting ready
kareem and i are gonna do a show
uh for howard and jim so what what well
give me
you haven't had the conversation yet uh
bill walton here on the rich eisen show
but
what what will that conversation be
about you and kareem
talking about this current team and
obviously reliving
some glory days that that bruins
what we're trying to do is try to
recreate what it was like
to be part of ucla and the team and the
history and the dynasty of
john wooden and chancellor young and jd
morgan that incredible athletic director
and ducky drake who were the four
pillars of the athletic community there
at ucla for so long
and what if you've ever seen that hbo
documentary called the ucla dynasty
it's really a spectacular program in
terms of
most of the things that have dealt with
john wooden and ucla has been on
have been on his impact on people's
lives
over the course of what happened to them
us after we left ucla but this was about
the time this was about sydney wicks and
this was about
kareem and lucius allen and mike warren
and
gail goodrich and walt hazard and jamal
wilkes and greg lee and henry bibby and
marcus johnson and
dave myers who sadly passed away but all
these incredible players and larry
hollyfield and larry farmer
and it was just so funny so we're going
to try to share
and create what that experience was like
and then transitioned it to today and
how thrilled
and and overjoyed we are with
with nick cronin what he has done is
simply uh the greatest story ever told
and we needed a miracle and we got a
miracle here and now we're on the crest
of a wave where paradise waits
but we have an unbelievable opponent in
front of us
because gonzaga they are special
and they are a team for the ages and
this guy mark few so very similar to
john wooden
and all the players that they have come
on
i was sitting there i watched the
conference of champions every single
night
and all these terrific teams and there
should have been eight teams in the
conference of champions but or
but stanford and arizona state were just
bedeviled by injuries and arizona
was not eligible for the tournament and
so we still got
five and i think what four of them went
to the elite eight and now
uh one of them is still alive in the
final four and then
two in the women's side so it's just
been a fantastic year
and i watched the conference of
champions and i just i've been on usc's
bandwagon driving the trains right all
season long and how
great they are and they came out and
gonzaga they just made them look like
they weren't even ready to play and
that's what great teams do
they define the terms of the conflict
and that's what ucla is challenged to do
is to not let gonzaga just run and flow
i mean
gonzaga it's like that it's like the
columbia river coming down
it's like celilo falls before they put
the dallas dam
up there and took away the indians
fishing spots
it was just such a beautiful beautiful
place up there in the northwest with
coeur d'alene
and the gorge and all these different
magnificent volcanoes and lava flows
and now you've got this gonzaga team
which ucla
is up against and gonzaga is is a team
for the ages and this is going to be the
ultimate challenge but
what great champions do i mean think of
what muhammad ali did
did you remember his book in the late
70s i think it was just called the
greatest
and it opened with it opened with
in the ring in africa against george
foreman
in the first round and that was like the
first paragraph of the book
muhammad ali who was supremely confident
and just the greatest of all time in
terms of his
impact on the world and and he goes
he goes in there and all of a sudden he
finds himself all by himself
against george foreman and then he and
then everything had to change but
as the great champions do they make the
other team play their game they turn him
to be
uh to become irrelevant cannon fodder
and that's generally what gonzaga has
been able to do
to all of their opponents this year they
i i just
love the way they play i love their
culture style and identity
everything about them is just over the
top fantastic they're players
timmy suggs ayahi uh corey kissberg
and then nem hard and then watson and
they just keep coming they're totally
interchangeable
and they remind me so much of the boston
celtics in the early 70s one of the
great teams ever
cowans have the check silas nelson jojo
white
don cheney from the houston cougars
alvin hayes and then he either had paul
westfall or charlie scott
it also reminds me of a of a classical
music symphony
maybe it's tchaikovsky maybe it's
mozart maybe it's beethoven's crashing
thunder but whatever it is
it's a whole group a whole team
in unison following the coach's lead
it's almost like
it's very it's not even almost it is
like being in the pit at a grateful dead
concert
when they have broken into the songs of
today
help on the way flip knot franklin's
tower
saint stephen let's get going
let's drive this thing over the top get
in our own volcanic explosion
and let's see who can play who's got a
game and who's ready to go
when you got a ticket you don't need a
miracle you got a ticket you're going i
got a mess with one
i got a ticket on westwood one with
howard general right
i got some great i got a seat next to
jim gray who's just going to be
working the phone he's going to be
everywhere with everybody
it's going to be a terrific show there
we want to salute all these
great athletes who have worked so hard
we wish
that everybody is going to be safe and
we just hope and
hope that we can get the equity on the
women's side that they
that they deserve and that it's on our
soul
it's sustaining stigma that is that is
just unfair and not
right at all stand up we're willing to
kneel down we're doing it
willing to take any steps necessary to
get them what they
deserve and when i talk when i see this
women's team play
boy stanford is just over the top
no and i agree with you too bill walton
here on the rich eisen show we're going
to be
taking a break and we'll see everyone
else in hour number three but i've got
two minutes left here on peacock okay
with bill walton so bill before i before
i let you go i got
two minutes to the old heart out at the
end of the hour uh my i've got my
eye on the clock my social media guy uh
tj jefferson has
has taken out of storage that we have
here my my uh my rear
windshield that we have kept here it is
a keepsake oh yes
yes it is bill it is a keepsake and uh
somewhere around here is your sweet note
that you sent me
saying that you wanted to pay for it if
you noticed that that was never cached
ever laurie's the cfo she's the ceo
that's cheap everything
but i just work here this is a badge of
honor
that i got to drive you to your spot so
you could go home on time from the katy
perry video
this is i love you bill walton to me
that this this
this windshield may be cracked but it is
a sign of cohesiveness and love
and spiritualness that's what i think
when i see this
i'm the luckiest guy in the world and
even though as we look around
at a world growing dark and mean and the
sadness and the pain and the suffering
and bob dylan sings
everything is broken i can always find
joy hope happiness optimism and a path
forward
on the rich eisen show i am indeed the
luckiest guy in the world
even if i do have a tendency to break
tesla with
what was your chair right i mean i
remember it's a hardback metal chair
that i'm sure you must still have to
keep your back
i'm sitting in that same chair right now
and the chair is saying
don't get me near that tesla leave me
away from that tesla
please i can't take it anymore i'm
carrying this
i'm carrying this awful burden in myself
and my own metal soul of this
plastic and iron steel rubber chair
here that's been supporting me for all
these years and i let it down
i put it in a precarious position no it
was me i just didn't want to move my
child seat out of the back i thought i
could fit it all and i shut it and it
shattered and you were you were you were
you are the best bill i will take you
anywhere i will drive you anywhere i
will do anything for you and i
appreciate the call here
you were there you should have put me in
the child seat
i can't wait to see that take care of
yourself bill have a great weekend
i love rich eisen i love the rich eisen
show
yes where all dreams come true have a
wonderful everything forever
for eternity times infinity let's go
bill walton everybody hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here